another Kamala staffer flees America's
Worst laugher
oh thanks Emily
oh but does the giggler have clout if
Biden drops out yet another Kamala
Harris staffer is leaving her office
making it the most popular office to
leave since Matt lauers
[Applause]
yeah yeah so do I this time it's
communications director Jamal Simmons
who held the post for only a year which
for a Kamala staffer is like holding
your breath underwater for a month
apparently his wife got a job in New
York and his family needs to relocate
which is likely code for honey we need
to get the hell away from this cackling
nut job and you know things are bad when
a family announces a move to New York
sure there's crime and failing schools
and urine in the streets but at least no
more babbling about buses
but despite the fact that Kamala loses
staffers faster than my Proctologist
loses pens Kamala still somehow one of
the more popular Democrats on the board
for 2024. although Biden's still the
front runner a recent poll finds that
when you take Joe out of the equation
Kamala is the favorite among the bunch
I know to be fair taking this poll is
like asking which finger you would like
removed
from your butt
at 32 she's well ahead of Sanders Buddha
judge Newsom and even Liz Warren
prompting Liz to ask how
[Applause]
that could bode well for Harris weather
in 2024 down the road when you consider
Joe Biden's push to reorder the
Democratic primary calendar this is
boring that plan would make South
Carolina First where Harris is expected
to do well among black voters but I
Wonder has she improved her public
speaking skills at all especially when
it comes to rules and norms
and we agreed to advance specific rules
and Norms in space International rules
and norms regarding rules and Norms we
are working together to develop norms
for the responsible and peaceful uses of
outer space more specifically regarding
rules and norms and international rules
and norms and establish rules and Norms
to govern space activities
I'll have what she's on
but in the words of the great Britney
Spears Hit Me Baby One More Time
with bongos
and we agreed to advance specific rules
and Norms in space International rules
regarding rules and Norms we are working
together to develop norms for the
responsible and peaceful uses of outer
space more specifically regarding rules
and norms and international rules and
norms
and establish rules and Norms to govern
space activities
everything's better with bongos
but
what's the big guy think about all this
oh no no no look kamala's not gonna
challenge me I keep her busy you know I
get her together with kids and have her
talk about uh outer space you know she
said I love the moon all that stuff but
I don't know if she likes me every time
I see her she high fives me but she
leans away
what are you lead it away for Kamala
what do you think I'm going to come in
close for a little squeeze and sniff
[Applause]
So Jamie
Jamie I did some research as a citizen
of Alaska you weren't allowed to vote
unless you produce the skin of a harp
seal is this true yeah that's a hundred
percent true I I haven't voted in a
couple years wow that's good yeah good
for the seals yeah it's just so
dangerous you know it's dangerous what
do you make this this recent finding
well when I heard the communications
director for Kamal I was leaving I think
I was like everyone I was like she has a
communications director
what what does he say to her he's like
oh I like that repeat it over and over
until people change the channel
I can't believe I Would by the way did
you guys know if um you invite Kamala to
a dinner party she always brings the
word sell it
um
it was really silly I'll show myself I
would love to see I would love both of
them to run and I would give anything to
see a debate between Kamala and Joe
Biden I would give anything to see that
wouldn't that be sofa she would keep
repeating stuff over and over and it
would be good because he would need her
to
Chris what is this what does this say
about all the other names in this bunch
of
this crowd it's like the Democrats have
the worst bench of all time I mean by
the way we're still pretending that
mayor Pete Pete Buda judge who's like
career is I was mayor of a small town in
Indiana and then I didn't show up to do
my job in the Biden Administration is
seriously considered presidential Timber
like that's really terrifying uh I'll
say this about Kamala Harris she's a lot
like Hillary Clinton uh in the sense
that she's shrill and unlikable
um but unlike unlike Hillary she's an
idiot I mean she you know like Hillary
at least knows her stuff she's obnoxious
she's the smartest girl in class she
wants you to know it Kamala has no idea
what the hell she's doing she spends all
her time trying to sound smart I for one
would pay good money to see Trump and
Kamala Harris on a debate stage
you wouldn't even need the Bongos in the
background we used to just uh engineer
these debates that are independent of
this presidential election cat because
that just seems we're entertaining don't
you agree with me that's not the
question off season yeah do you think
this information is reliable isn't this
more about just name recognition like
the fact that they just know who Kamala
Harris is probably yes especially when
you see how well she did when she
actually tried to run for president
which isn't she didn't do well no
I think that uh like everyone says like
the worst kind of boss is like the Elon
Musk who's like a jerk like you have to
work your ass off work so hard I have no
mercy on you but actually the worst kind
is a secret musk which is what Kamala is
because I think of that you know piece
that came out last year about how is
this abusive environment nobody can
stand it she's such a jerk but people go
in there thinking like oh she just
babbles about how it's crazy we can see
the moon and then you get in there and
she's like yeah you have no idea what
you signed up for so signed up for isn't
it kind of interesting Emily people kind
of look at her working for her as a tour
of Duty it's like yeah I did two years
in Afghanistan oh yeah I did two years
in Kamala yeah
but
only as conscription though yes have you
guys noticed in the revolving door that
is her staff it's all the same names too
every single person in there is like
they did a tour with Carrie they did it
it's all the same tiny bench just like
those recycled tired names of Democrats
that they're floating for 2024. Stacy
Abrams she still has not conceded 2018
and they're like what about her that
just goes to the same tired exhausting
depressing tiny bench that the Democrat
Party has they literally have no one
because everyone has only spent their
time being part of that machine that's
why Biden has been literally in that
same chair or near it for the last
hundred years they don't have anyone new
they don't have anyone young fresh maybe
actually intelligent maybe actually
authentic they've called her environment
abusive they say it's soul-crushing Soul
destroying 30 White House staffers went
on the record of I believe CNN
um they were Anonymous but they went on
the on the record 30. could you imagine
if that was any other employer I mean
Elon Musk just dares to be transparent
and like throw up in the curtains he
actually pays his employees and expects
them to show up she's a total monster a
dumb one too to your point tiny bench
tiny bench I rode one of those in the
Peewee League
up next climate Dogma forbids charging a
car and having kids hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else